after the death of conservative Justice
Antonin Scalia in 2016
President Obama nominated Merrick
garland to replace him
moderate liberal garland would have
shifted the balance of the high court to
the left with the election approaching
Senate Republicans refused to hold a
hearing on Garland's nomination the
American people should have a say in the
courts direction and then Obama's term
came to an end and Donald Trump entered
the White House he nominated the
conservative justice Neel Gorsuch to
replace Scalia
then when the swing vote Justice Kennedy
retired Trump went with the solidly
conservative Brett Kavanaugh to take his
spot
liberals concerned that a conservative
majority may dominate the court for a
generation and overturned key precedents
liked Roe vs. Wade have responded by
reviving calls to expand the membership
of the Supreme Court to include as many
as 15 justices their goal is to water
down conservative influence the proposal
harkens back to the 1930s when FDR
aggressively pushed the idea of pork
packing because his New Deal policies
were being declared unconstitutional
they are no longer public servants in
the way that we have always imagined
them to be all the options are on the
table
Ilia soman a law professor at George
Mason University and a contributor to
the valla conspiracy blog sat down with
reason to discuss the revival of court
packing proposals on the left and how
they could undermine the institution of
judicial review do you think Democrats
have a point though over the Merrick
garland nomination and how that was all
handled I think you could reasonably
argue about whether the Republicans
acted improperly even if you do believe
that the Republicans acted improperly
which is a I think a reasonable belief
it doesn't follow the court packing is
justifiable retaliation
court packing would be a major
escalation beyond what previously
happened with Garland or anything to
previously happen with Supreme Court
nomination battles over the last several
decades because unlike simply blocking
the nominee to one particular seat this
would at one fell swoop changed the
majority on the court and add multiple
justices who would serve for decades
moreover it would have the potential to
create a dangerous cycle of retaliation
whereas simply blocking one nominee
challi ation and kind would just be
blocking the next Republican nominee in
a similar circumstances the next time
the Republicans nominate someone when
the Democrats control the Senate if the
Democrats retaliated in kind and that
way one could argue about whether they
were justified in blocking a particular
nominee dependent depending on what you
think about that person that yours
prudence but Sir don't we procedurally
it would not be an escalation and it
would not threaten the long term
undermining of judicial review
whereas court packing would have that
effect it would be retaliating would be
like retaliating to conventional bombing
with nuclear bombing
I think retaliating with the same kind
of bombing as the other side did that
might be entirely reasonable deploying
the nuclear weapons is a very different
kind of thing and a lot of this harkens
back to of course FDR and his proposal
in 1937 to pack the court this plan will
save our National Constitution from
hardening of the judicial artery why do
you think that failed and do you see an
appetite with this Democratic Party to
actually get this done in one sense his
proposal failed and it failed in large
part because many people in his own
party were afraid of it for example
senator Burton we were himself a New
Deal Democrat led the opposition in the
Senate to this and they worried rightly
in my view that court packing would
destroy the effectiveness of judicial
review and undermine this important
check on government power an interesting
question to ask is if a Democratic
president proposed something similar
today would he or she also get
opposition within their own party and
it's difficult to know for sure I think
a lot of moderate Democrats are worried
of this idea and even some liberal ones
like Cory Booker who pointed out
recently this tip for tact dynamic on
the other hand we do have today a more
ideologically unified Republican or a
Democratic Party also republican party
as well but the Democratic Party is
what's relevant here and therefore
they're relatively fewer moderates than
there were in an
1930s and also there may be more anger
specifically focused at the Supreme
Court today or even more than in the
1930s so it's possible that they
wouldn't be the same resistance the last
point that would make on this is the Wow
FDR failed to pack the court some
scholars believe that he succeeded in
the sense that some believe that the
court was effectively intimidated in
changing their position on some issues
that he cared about this is disputed by
experts in some believe that the court
shift was not at all related to the
court packing plan but to the extent
there's a perception that FDR FDR's plan
did work in a sense that might increase
the desirability of trying this from the
point of view of current Democrats a
couple of the last recent appointees are
very young I look at some of the recent
nomination fights and it seems like a
lot of importance is being placed on one
judge and I think a lot of people would
say well if one judge can tip the
political scales in this country should
there be some sort of judicial reform is
there something that you could get
behind
certainly as people continue to live
longer and longer we could get to
situations where the average life
expectancy in as high as 110 or 120 or
even higher and so you get justices who
if they serve for life will be on the
court for 50 60 70 years at some point
that would be intolerable and would
strengthen the case for some sort of
term limits for the court many people
have proposed 18 year terms but we could
argue about exactly how long is ideal
similarly there may might be reasonable
to say we want to diminish the
significance of any one vote in the
Supreme Court and that could also
justify increasing its size so long as
the increase was done in such a way that
it wouldn't just allow one president to
completely pack the court by appointing
five or six or seven new justices you
could potentially stagger to new seats
you could also combine it with some sort
of term limits and preferably any such
reform which would require a
constitutional amendment that amendment
hopefully would also include a permanent
cap on the number of justices on the
Supreme Court so as to forestall future
court packing so in term limits an
increase in the size of the court that's
done in a way that avoids court packing
I think both of those might be useful
reforms but note that neither of those
by itself would give Democrats the thing
that many of them most want right now
which is to reverse the current narrow
5'4 conservative majority on the court
also these other types of reforms
probably would require a constitutional
amendment which makes them more
difficult to enact in a simple
conventional court packing why should
people be paying attention to this issue
in this election cycle and ones that
follow the Supreme Court and also the
lower federal courts decide a wide range
of issues that are extremely important
to many people
everything from abortion to the balance
of power between the federal and state
governments to civil liberties all
property rights all sorts of important
things so therefore even if people don't
know much about the courts which polls
show that they don't the courts do have
an important effect on their lives
moreover if court packing does happen
and you get this cycle of retaliation
this quite valuable institution would be
undermine and protections for our civil
liberties for separation of power for
limits on the power of federal
government for property rights and so on
all of that would be significantly
weakened over time and I think even if
liberals perhaps in particular would be
happy to see the current conservative
Supreme Court majority reversed and I
can understand to some extent how they
feel about that in the long run both day
and the rest of us would be likely to be
significantly worse off if court packing
becomes a regular part of American
politics and once one party succeeds in
doing it there is a very high
probability at the other party where we
tally in kind
you
[Music]